good yeah yep are you stunned by this
whole thing Oh Jay pulling out at the
last second it was really it's thing
it's a cute story I went straight down
to Katie Couric's office and I said you
got me if you need me Katie I said I'll
do the hour that he was gonna do and
they did and they went with the painting
guy and stay Ave they threw me out
they really throw you as a Three Stooges
movie I can't believe that I would I
think a lot of America would be riveted
because there are a lot of questions
I've wanted to ask you and II really
have yeah Wow
I have no idea what I talked about fun
it'd be a great hour I'd be looking
forward to that well Andy I understand
actually correct me if I'm wrong but I
understand this weekend you had a bit of
an adventure that they wanted to share
with us here at the top of the show well
when I got this job I decided that I was
going to sort of use it to make some of
my dreams come true that's what it's for
now xx we like it for my own person yeah
exactly that's what these shows are for
yeah just have fun with it right exactly
and one thing I really always wanted to
do and I never have is to drive a
motorcycle like a big hog a Harley you
know a big Harley hog that's been your
fantasy oh yeah I've always wanted to
but I never knew anybody that had one
and I you know I didn't know anybody
that knew how to ride one right right I
heard that the Queensboro motorcycle
Club which is a club out on Long Island
having what they call a casino run I'm
sorry I don't know this stuff what is a
casino run it's just like there's
different it's a all the bikers get
together and they go on this sort of
different legs of this route and they
all go on the route together and they
stop at different places and do biker
things and there's like a big biker
stuff biker picnic at the end Oh a biker
picnic again yeah that sounds like fun
actually and I thought what better place
to learn how to ride a motorcycle you'll
go along and you'll see maybe someone
will let you ride there I thought I'd
just follow the route you know and
follow the route that all the bikers are
going to be on and try and hitch a ride
this sounds really exciting it and
you've got a remote to file down this
whole thing ledge dumb and Andy Richter
search for a motorcycle ride take a look
we're in the middle of we're going from
point to point on the the casino run
I asked some of the bikers if they'd let
me ride with them and they said no so we
have to go by ban but that's okay cuz my
buddy Peter here those are some of the
guys that wouldn't let me ride with
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why couldn't you arrange a biker for me
to ride with for an it thing off I've
come here today to see if someone can
teach me how to ride a motorcycle you
know it's something I've wanted to do
for a long time and I fear what better
place in a biker picnic to find someone
to teach me how to ride so gonna go see
if just how nice these guys are
[Music]
do you have a motorcycle here yes do do
you think I could ride it
do I think you can ride it I wouldn't
let you ride it you feel confident
enough to ride this I wouldn't let him
ride though I don't think he can handle
it
would you guys let me ride your bike
very funny
[Music]
I have to buy my own it ain't like you
to borrow someone's caught a ride no
okay your club got to get a new clutch
you take my bike out and you crash in
I'm out of motorcycle right what do you
say oops sorry
while I'm keeping one third of an Easy
Rider theme and that what would a biker
picnic be without the bad acid trip so
I'm just gonna make believe that this is
acid punch just iced tea
[Music]
do you think that I could maybe make a
spin on your bike today and you know
know like learn how to ride on your
and now what do you do for a party
psychotherapists really you know any
other motive people writing
psychotherapists I'm sure there have to
help people do you think maybe you could
let me ride your motorcycle
yeah I think we can work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah you were fine in that day thank you
very nice I've never felt more manly
nice job all around thank you I've had
that acid trip actually thank you and a
highlight yeah I'll tell you about it
afternoon alright folks we're gonna take
a break we'll be right back with Paul
Sorvino
[Applause]